has the world gone mad with this woke
ideology and is it destroying sci-fi
welcome to scitec your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so first of all very quickly what is
woke
a lot of conspiracy theorists and people
that believe aliens visiting in the new
world orders have to get us believe that
work is a good thing
that we're all wandering around to sleep
and that to be woke means that you're
awake to the truth the woke ideology
began really though is a fight against
racism in america
um but a lot of comments i get on my
channel when i'm talking about reboots
or or new projects that are coming
through
don't seem to think that being woke is a
good thing they seem to think that
sci-fi and fantasy and lots of other tv
and movies have to represent everybody
in their shows every gender every
culture every ethnicity and that even if
it's detrimental to the story that
there's an obsession
with this ideology of being woke
i put a question out on my youtube
channel is the woke ideology destroying
science fiction
i got 104 votes over the last week
77 agree that it is
that's nearly 80 people out of 104 that
agreed that woke is destroying sci-fi
only 10 percent
14 people 104 believe that it isn't and
13 said yes sometimes it does
that really surprised me i was really
shocked by that answer so i thought i've
got to have a look into it and i've got
to try to figure out what are people so
worried about
so for example i recently did a video
about the book rogers reboot that's
planned
one of the comments said ah they'll make
him betty rogers
they seem to be real concerned that they
might change the gender of a major
character and that change would be for
no good reason other than to be
woke in science fiction the most famous
example of a major character being
turned into a woman
is probably starbuck from the battlestar
galactica's reboot series
but that worked cara thrace became one
of the most loved characters in that
series generally um dirk benedict
actually came out when the series plans
and it was announced it was going to be
a woman and said that it was disgusting
disgraceful i can't believe this is
happening you're ruining my character
but then later dirk benedict and katie
sackoff actually did
film video shoots together and there's
photos of them smoking cigars together
and things and he said he changed his
mind and he loved the character
i'm going to come back to that in a
minute though because there was a reason
why they turned star book into a woman
if we're going to talk about major male
roles being turned into women we've got
to mention ghostbusters right
the 2016 film was it
just
just awful from beginning to end
there does seem to have been
that they turned the major characters
into women and that there was a large
media backlash and social media and
everything else people hated the idea
now the writers and the producers and
the actresses involved seem to they do
seem to have reacted to that and there
is elements of the film where you do
think there's an agenda to this
that all of a sudden the fact that they
are women has become a point to the film
and to me that was a joke it ruined the
movie
but it actually wasn't ghostbusters
biggest problem the biggest problem of
ghostbusters is this is a bad film it's
written really badly it doesn't respect
the original movie at all that i don't
mean in that they were men and now
they're women so they're not respecting
the original film i mean that the comedy
is completely different
the comedy of ghostbusters is subtle
it's sarcastic
it's not really like there's no like big
jokes or slapstick or things like that
but that's what they tried to do
in the ghostbusters movie the bit where
the kids heads gets
incoherent and doesn't make sense at
times it's just a bad film and that's
the problem i have with it it's
unwatchable not because the main
actresses have boobs instead of willys
but because it's written
badly james bond james bond has just
ended daniel craig spoilers they killed
him
so i think they're going to have to
reboot james bond and i and i actually
have an idea for this i think they
should reboot james bond as a much much
younger character like still in the navy
sort of thing maybe he's like 19 20 21
so i think they should reboot it from
the beginning that would make sense to
me but a lot of people have said well
let's make james bond a woman
it wouldn't work but the reaction again
in social media obviously did catch the
attention of the tv producers because
again spoiler alert double 07 in the
latest james bond movie is a woman and
to make it a little bit worse for the
people who get really angry about this
stuff they made a black woman
and her character is phenomenal and that
is the main argument
a lot of people make about this is that
if you've got a strong male role
don't turn into a woman just write a
strong female character
that's what they did for the last double
07 movie
they pointed out that yes james bond
doesn't necessarily have to be a man
or more importantly double o 7 doesn't
have to be a man
i would argue actually that james bond
does the female doctor who
so they turned doctor into a woman he
got an upgrade as she said in the um
series
um i love that and i don't think being
male is um intrinsic too again is it
isn't central to doctor who's character
it doesn't matter
the whole point is that he changes
completely the point is he's not
actually human for start so is he a male
anyway
um but they always joke with that
whenever he changes he sort of goes oh
god at my ginger oh god am i northern
and all these sort of jokes they make
jokes about that so this time they made
a joke about him becoming a woman and it
really worked for me
again the show has not really succeeded
because it's been written badly the show
runner is the problem not the actress
and i really think it's a shame that
jody whittaker is going to be leaving at
the end of the next series because the
original showrunner has come back and i
suspect that show is going to improve a
lot i've already seen the first episode
and to be honest
it's already better than any other last
two series but changing the gender of
series isn't isn't just the only thing
that people really get angry about
recently the advert for the new light
year movie came out and buzz lightyear
is no longer going to be voiced by tim
allen is instead going to be voiced by
chris evans now people have kicked off
about that because they believe that
decision was based on tim allen's
politics he's a bit of a left-wing quite
vocal
um sort of person he
he's got some negative headlines
recently because of some of his
political views
now a lot of people have said well
disney have gone crazy they're just
doing that because they don't agree with
his politics so they've hired somebody
else
is that the case though
or is it because tim allen's career is
most definitely on a downward trend
his last few tv series have been awful
he hasn't made a movie that's made any
money for about 15 years
um and he's definitely not the box
office draw that chris evans is
also though i would argue that
filmmakers want to get away from the
pixar
toy story movies that gives me a point
that sometimes it's a good idea to
change the gender of a character because
times have moved on and because it can
actually move the storyline on
there's a lot of rumors about a
highlander remake and i argued when i
did a video about highlander that they
could make the ramirez character a woman
now a lot of people whoa can't do that
can't do that's awoke
um that's ridiculous don't talk stupid
ramirez is a man
and i said well yeah but it's not it's
not that relevant because
the one argument was there are other
female characters in highlanders just
use one of them they just make one of
them more popular
and i would agree with you
there was a female character in battle
star galactica adam's daughter and they
didn't bring her back to the to the next
series
but why didn't they do that
well starbuck
again being a man the writers decided
this was a really important character
but they decided that as a as a
character for the new series it was a
bit boring it's been done over and over
again so they thought how do we make
starbucks character more interesting how
do we make this character relevant to a
new generation
and how we make it interesting again
make it a woman
make starbuck a woman and all of a
sudden all of those same things cigar
smoking
rebel rousing you know
character all of a sudden becomes
interesting
and the writers sort of as soon as they
thought that they went but they had
loads of ideas and starbuck became
probably the most important character
and definitely the most memorable
character from that series
with highlander they could do something
similar
make the ramirez character a woman
they think about it
she turns up when the highlander's
confused and doesn't really know what's
going on i need to train it
she turns up and kicks his ass
to begin with and that'll be funny
because one of the things they're
talking about doing is doing henry
cavill as the highlander i hope you can
use god's accent
um better than a french accent um but
the you know so a little i think little
michelle you should turn up and kick his
ass then train him
he she then becomes like a mother-like
figure and then when the kergun turns up
and lobs your head off that will be far
more of an impact into the movie than
when sean connery was killed
um
i actually think that that gives
something to the story and adds an
element a layer to the story that the
first film may be lacked a little bit
um because what's worse than losing a
father figure
losing a mother figure
so this really comes down to my point
that sci-fi has always been woke star
trek is woke it's always been work from
beginning from the very start let that
be a less battlefield where the
characters come on and they have the
they're black on one side and white on
the other and the one character is
trying to escape from the planet because
the guys that are black on this side are
white on this side and then the others
are the other way around and the other
way around think that being black on
this side the other is wrong
that is not a subtle metaphor about
racism that is an in your face
about racism and the racism isn't just
wrong it's stupid
they're the same what difference does it
make we and then we have the famous kirk
and uhuru kissing so you know not subtle
very woke
tng had episodes that were basically the
same as well we have the transgender
episode
the outcast
is an episode about riker basically
beginning a relationship of fallen in
love with a transgender character
they are they're all sort of like their
thai species don't have a gender they're
not male or female but she was born
believing she was a female and she was
fighting for those rights and
then obviously while she's on starship
enterprise and she begins a relationship
with riker
that again is not a subtle metaphor
about gender equality and gender choice
and i know it's a massively complicated
issue and psychology and everything else
comes into it
but it is an important issue that we
should consider
and as it's such a difficult and and
challenging issue in society
sci-fi should try to tackle it and it
did
nearly 30 years ago remembering that for
um star trek the next generation the
episode the measure of a man with data
is about slavery
it's about ownership it's about freedom
i would argue that actually every robot
in every sci-fi series ever is about the
same thing
the robots become our slaves in lots of
ways that they then don't have the
freedoms that we have
that is again not a very subtle metaphor
about slavery and about freedom about
personal growth about what it is to be
human
that is throughout sci-fi
it's a backbone of sci-fi it's always
been there but is that what's happening
now
i would argue that sometimes people
really do focus on star trek and star
wars for this
um
it's not always
sometimes the
metaphor isn't very subtle and it is
shoved down our throat and it seems to
be
um growing and increasing and we could
see more of that
but i would argue that the things that
you're angry about in star wars and star
trek aren't because of woke they're
because of bad writing
star wars solo is a bad film it's just a
bad film it's badly written badly badly
cast everything everything was wrong
with it
large chunks of star trek discovery
aren't particularly a problem because
they woke they're a problem because
they're badly written
there is no i have no problem with a
male character becoming a female
character if it's relevant to the story
or makes the character more interesting
in some way or making the character gay
like they did with the sulu character as
a little nod to the original actor
there is
nothing wrong with that when there's a
point to it
when there's a reason for it
when they do it for no reason they do it
just because they can
or just because they want to make
headlines
that is the problem and
i would make the point really strongly
here that a lot of the time when
filmmakers do this and they turn a
character into a woman it's not because
of being woke
it's because they want to get some
attention
that is cynical
but it works so is woke to some sci-fi
no
how can it be
sci-fi has always been woke
is bad writing and lazy writing
destroying some sci-fi oh god yeah
so if you're going to get angry about
something get angry about that
now as a little challenge please if
you've got to the end of the video
and you're not completely furious at me
already
have a look at the comments
i want to bet you there are a lot of
comments on there about how i'm wrong
from people that have not watched the
video
and
if you see them please shout them out
because this is a debate that's really
quite important
and go on my discord server i'll put the
link in the description
there is a series there there so you can
go and ask the question is work
destroying sci-fi and i'd love to see
your comments and finally please go and
join our facebook page you can go and
put all your silly little memes on there
you can start discussions on there it's
completely free and open as long as
people don't take advantage of that um
please there's a link in description as
well
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out
now
that's my 20 minutes on
my opinion i would love to now hear
yours so please leave a comment thank
you very much and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
the series elementary with johnny lee
miller it's about sherlock holmes now
they modernized sherlock holmes and made
him a womanizing major drug addict which
to be honest kind of made sense but then
they made
joan watson played by lucy liu
that didn't work for me at all they did
it for no good reason other than they
wanted
somebody pretty on the photos
um lucy lou probably didn't have a job
or maybe she was under contract with
somebody i don't know um but they wanted
somebody pretty and then maybe they
wanted some headlines when they when
this show got started they did it for
capitalistic reasons they didn't do it
for anything to do with the show but in
the same series they made
but in the same series natalie dormer
played a character now he she played
sherlock holmes sort of like love
interest it was the person is that that
character the lady from sherlock holmes
that the stellar coast was in love with
um they then twisted it and made it into
jamie moriarty
moriarty is a woman
to be honest though they did that i
before i didn't see it coming it
completely threw me i was just like whoa
oh my god that's amazing my royalties
woman
but also for the storyline it kind of
made sense
that
sherlock holmes is main arch enemy
his nemesis moriarty is his equal in
lots of ways
so it kind of made sense that he would
fall in love with his equal
that
the disease in some ways but his
opposite in others
um
it's the it's kind of if you think about
it it's kind of the perfect relationship
so
in that sense they changed the gender of
a character but it was it was actually
important to the story it actually made
sense to the story added something to
the story but also it was just bloody
brilliant